dimanche les plaies on est posée là
aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour la suite
de notre petit l'aspect sur inside a
écouté j'ai envie de comprendre ce que
c'est que cet endroit voilà qu'est ce
qu'ils font à manipuler les gens
pourquoi ils le font qui se rapporte à
ces gens cela rapporte quelque chose
alors oui c'est chaud lit alors un petit
levier on va pas se mentir on l'activé
de ce pas
ça ouvre ça et je suppose qu'on va
contrôler quelqu'un qui va sortir de ce
hangar
oui et elle m'a fait peur ce qui sortit
de la droite dans l'ombre alors il ya
quoi y'a deux dalles à activer c'est ça
ouais bah j'ai compris on se détache on
ferme sa up et ça va équilibrer les cas
requis entre les deux perso je suis fier
de moi c'est la troisième ligne du jeu
je dois d'être quand même fier de moi
regardez on va les faire courir comme ça
hop voilà là on est bon la distance et
maintenant la même c'est un peu égoïste
ce qu'on fait on les laisse bien dans
leur mère dans la noirceur et nous on
s'enfuit vers la lumière c'est quoi ça
c'est le sort de prison
pourquoi il y aurait des fois ya des
bruits qui me font perdre vous entendez
sur deux battements de coeur un peu
traître et flippant tout comme la tête
de cet enfant qui finalement n'a pas de
visage à sa passion du sable densément
on a pied à la salle glissade la voilà
up la gouttière super regardez voyez on
dirait qu'ils sont réduits à l'état
d'esclaves et qui sont pas maîtres de
leur corps on dirait qu'ils marchent
sous le contrôle d'un mec qui a le
casque en fait coûté on essaie d'en
savoir plus sur ce délire aller en
escalade
hop là on est finalement le petit frère
de john drake ou [ __ ] j'en ai glissé
qui est au nom puisque je fais qu'est ce
que je fais ok c'est bon j'ai paniqué
alors le mur et péter on saute sur
bâtiment d'en face d'un messie
d'entreprise immense bec c'est microsoft
microsoft dans dix mille ans quand linux
aura pris le dessus ou pas avoir merde
non je pensais qu'il allait revenir foot
c'est affreux qu'on se casse la gueule
ces offres mais ok pas deux fois la même
erreur donc je pense pas aux pieds sur x
pour descendre doucement c'est ça oui et
puis teints c'est elle je suis sûr et
certain que supprimer de leur corps
c'est sûr ok on y est [ __ ] fuyons mecs
ça fait tellement peur on peut pas se
baisser la dent faut tirer ça va faire
du bruit
non c'est bon ça ce sont pas maîtres de
leur corps dépêche toi petit caux
à ses bons voeux en janvier ok [ __ ] c
c'est à croire les changements de décors
d'ambiance de c ur
ok je me suis jeté dessus c'est ça non
c'est bon petite roulade
on peut remonter on va faire de ce
parent n'est pas trouvé avec les rats
comment je fais là je suis baisé la main
s'il ya trop d'écarts mais comment je
fais un peu pas juste prendre l'échelle
voilà [ __ ] il nous faut tourner en
bourrique
ok on est finalement là haut ils
construisent des robots non on dirait un
robot là bas au fond l'ombre il ya un
truc à faire
ouais ok mauvaise idée mais quelle idée
de merde où l on va en avoir besoin d r
c'est sûr on va pas prendre au cerveau
réseau le truc si nous voient ils nous
choque direct
après il faut l'allumer points qui font
attention à leurs élites v18
le
c'est chaud ça passa passa passa passe
ok c'est maintenant c'est maintenant
pourquoi il a pu s' de biceps [ __ ] je
suis mal placé pour parler mais quand
même à temps s'assoit ya pas besoin
d'allumer au premier abord en fait il
faut juste aller ouvrir la grille
revenir l'allumé y retourner je pense
voila voila et là on peut aller activé à
y retourner
ok on a réussi on se casse
[ __ ] c'est effrayant mais je comprends
pas ce qu'ils font aux gens et dans quel
but ça me stresse j'ai envie de savoir
le pourquoi du comment
et ça souvent on peut accéder au dehors
je pouvais voir ce robot de ma vie mon
gars franchement il fait quoi lui y'a
pas faire tomber la planche
dans ses bons coups devient parano ok on
arrive dans ce petit bec aux lots
séparés mission permettre de même non
non non fait fléchir fait j'ai recruté
contrôler fait j'en crois qu'on n'a
jamais vu un mec autant mourir sur
inside l on est bon on va duper la
machine tu as il est pas con le petit
cette chaise musicale dit que ça devait
s'arrêter pour y restions doivent avoir
les autres [ __ ] j'ai l'impression
d'être ses encours que le prof et que tu
regardes et tu toi et engueuler toi oh
merde
dans ces monts et merveilles fait bien
la démarche 1 c'est malin en fait c'est
un deux trois soleil voilà alors vouloir
sauter à droite en fait il nous teste
voir si on est très très ces petits fous
pas à la machine
oui bon on est pas qu on va sauter on
pas mentir est-ce que vos ouvriers ça la
question
allez c'est génial comme principe c'est
quoi c'est en fait si les riches diallo
penser avec les masques et où vous avez
à griller je vous ai du pet bon de fdp
c'est quoi le truc d'après ils font quoi
tu peux le temps de voir ils sont aussi
il se retourne
ok j'ai voulu m'entraîner je n'aurais
jamais dû ok c'est bon on y retourne
influe sur un demi tour et un autre demi
tour oh là là que moi je suis un gros
c'était les mouillages de faire de la
danse aulas il a qui notait le rebec
j'ai cru qu'ils aiment envoyer son
[ __ ] de ressorts dans l'anus on est
bon on va pouvoir y aller ou penser moi
je pense que oui on va pas attendre mais
qu on va pas marcher à la vitesse de ces
zombies indéfiniment et maintenant on
est surveillé encore [ __ ] mais non
c'est moi le mec me choque de nulle part
non c'est toi le cheikh t mais pourquoi
pourquoi
non non non vient parvient pas vraiment
vraiment vient pas j'aurais dû fuir
j'aurais dû fuir hockey d'aubry
montgrillet le chien n'est pas dupe les
humains sont dupes mais le chien est pas
dupe ok on se casse oui où aller a plus
désormais je me casse d'ici et je saute
et à chaque fois qu'un chien poursuit ya
un vide
je me suis fera quatre mecs bonjour les
gars [ __ ] csc effrayant dans le cher
monsieur mais non mais non tu as à lui
comme à arracher la culasse et pas à ce
pauvre cochon l'épisode précédent et si
j'attends là ok faut que j'attende pour
ensuite lui il arrive pas passer mur
voila ca technique d'accord et là on
arrive là on saute la survap on trouvera
les humains et on va le but et attend le
mec qui crée cet appareil le met à voir
mais tout de suite vite quoi c'est abusé
à elle a du coup lui optèrent pour un
outil réfute 1 j'adore ok on est bientôt
bon hop on est bon c'est parfait on met
ça sur le bouton qui se sait active la
porte de la web voilà on va se
reconnecter on va continuer à aimer du
coup le problème c'est que je peux plus
hautes et jusqu au casque c'est pas
grave et une caisse là c'est faux si
jouve ça je n'ai plus accès bas sinon on
semblait coup juge le descend mauvaise
idée
à bas la suite ou coup je me rends
compte parfois c'est génial mais juste
fait ça là et on va céder de l'autre
casse hop c'est parti
allez on passe au dessus du vide [ __ ]
moi je serai pas serein doit faire mal
au crâne quand même d'être suspendu par
les cheveux là
hélas ici je saute je décède dans
d'affreuses souffrances en vrai à l'ail
et d'alou tu regardais comment je peux
faire ça abbas et lui tu vas devoir
monter hockey hop hop
il y est c'est bon le conte ok
maintenant je fais comment [ __ ] faudra
un deuxième break pour pousser le truc
ayen deuxième casse mais non mais non
mais mais que ça part en couille la
double casque mais non mais non mais non
mais c'est jésus cet homme regardez
c'est jésus jésus et la vie ou qe 1
c'est un truc de ouf
bon alors des possibilités infinies
d'énigmes avec ça et voilà mais le
problème c'est que là s'il un kit de
trucs l'autre aussi en fait donc ça nous
arrange pas non on va laisser ça à vue
et c'est ok z'amis oreca ya une
plateforme en bas j'ai totalement oublié
je suis un gros coup on va mettre le
petit au dessus de la passerelle
on va mettre ce premier mec là ensuite
on va débrancher le petit mail claude
sud a passé les moeurs pas si fait que
le 2 je vais mourir ce qui fait que ça a
détaché le deuxième mecque du casque
donc on peut reprendre le contrôle de ce
deuxième break pour pousser la poubelle
[ __ ] si tout court mais bien ceux ci
c'était quand même compliqué ok donc on
avance fait ça j'ai galéré pour ce truc
on passe de l'autre côté qu'est ce qu'il
ya où là la fois que ce soit moi ça ça
va ouvrir une trappe et il y aurait une
piscine en bas c'est ça
devant on va pas avoir beaucoup de temps
c'est parti go voit la petite piscine
dans qabatya samba
peu importe où on est je vous avoue
juste les chiens qui me qu'ils me
foutent la pression pas un trou dans le
mur pour passer la non forcément un truc
à faire par là ça a réveillé une barre
on va pouvoir le tir et voilà allez
allez dépêche toi j'ai déjà plus
beaucoup de respiration [ __ ] j'ai
mourir non c'est bon on s'en est sorti
ça me permet d'accéder aux rebords et de
rentrer chez nous dire à maman tout ce
qu'on vient de voir
et d'appeler la police et 1 j'ai peur
qu'on se fasse grillé mais vraiment
salma un moment donné à quoi sert ce
bouton chute à saas à vider l'eau ces
bons ne jamais appuyer sur un bouton
sans savoir à quoi il sert une très
mauvaise idée hop c'est pour ça qu'on va
tout ce qui traduit y est c'est à voir
ce que ça fait pour cela il était cool
il nous a permis de traverser
ah non non on n'aurait pas dû en fait on
n'aurait pas du tout du énorme fail
c'est là qu'il faut aller vite c'est là
qu'il faut aller vite
voilà ça nous a permis d'accéder au
rebord et de passer en fait on a bien
fait d'appuyer dessus continue [ __ ]
sûr qu'on va tomber mais on va tout ce
qui est trop vive en fait ça me stresse
le reste ça va m'aider que c'est vivant
ou robotique ça me mettrait mal up
alors on recule l'étagère ainsi ça va la
ramener à surface et on va pouvoir aller
là-haut voilà c'est très bien allez on
attire vers l'euro bordiot
on va voir ce qu'il ya ok il ya une
trappe ya une trappe on ouvre on tombe
sur un mec de trappes la finale et
[ __ ] 1
assad et à ceux ci n'a servi à rien ok
j'ai encore fait un truc bien foireux en
fait fait la droite pas à gauche pour
accéder à la chaîne que je n'avais pas
vu hop voilà allez on y va où là
pourquoi la musique qui sont un train
[ __ ] mais qu'est ce qu'un train fait
là ses employés les riches glauque qui
vient ni pulls et les autres qui
touchait pas ah non là ça plaît pas la
lumière
non non je suis mort j'en ai marre de ce
resort ok j'ai compris la leçon on va
alors se cacher sous l'ombre de tuyaux
voilà on est bien voir tourner le truc
pour que la cage des centres très très
vite les parties non dans l'autre sens
allez je suis mort je suis mort je suis
mort jumain chemin chemin pendu par le
bras à celui tu arrêtes de versailles
mon cadavre
ok c'est parti allez allez allez le pcf
qui le contractent tu nous mets bien
aller faut y aller
d'accord il faut le faire en deux fois
tout simplement ta faut faire trois fois
c'est abuser un scandaleux cette lumière
là cette fois on est bon on va pouvoir
s'aider de la cage pour aller de l'autre
côté
désolé les pauvres gens ah ben non on va
dans la cage avec eu d'accord final on
est au milieu des pauvres gens à mais on
peut aller de l'autre côté en fait ok up
très bien [ __ ] encore la lumière non
non non non non ok j'ai compris à temps
ça tient chaud là c'est très surveillé
cet endroit là à [ __ ] parles tu lâches
pompiers installent ce que je t'ai dit
non on braque tu peux faire le pied
claque on est en zone invincibilité je
vous le dis là mais je vous le dis je
préfère vous prévenir la lumière revient
et fort heureusement on est dans l'ombre
la voilà la bonne pression ok on est
passé lire ok ça juste passer très très
bonne idée
dans tous les cas il ya forcément moyens
de revenir en arrière grâce à cette
petite habitants on va carrément dessin
en fait wow alors là mon cas on va dans
les bas-fonds de la map
c'est chaud ok bon bon on est en vie
c'est déjà ça
coutu et d'avancer tranquillement [ __ ]
la norme en haut là il se passe quoi là
dedans normalement il devrait pas y
avoir de robots on est dans les égouts
de la mama mais regardez pts l espèce de
canal qui marche au fond là c'est quoi
ça encore vous arrêtez avec vos
mauvaises surprises c'était monstre au
nom non si je pense que c'est des
scellés mais qu'on a utilisées qu'on a
signé jusqu'à l'os et qu'on jette à la
poubelle c'est la poubelle de cette
entreprise horrible c'est ça en ya des
chiens non mais chez les chiens vraiment
je vote pour les bannières à tout jamais
s'il vous plaît faites vraiment ils vont
m'attendre
après s'ils vont dans l'eau jaillit
elles vont pas dans l'eau mais si on se
souvient d'épisodes dab en cours court
court court courbe cours comment on peut
faire on la tient on va dans l'eau non
il va bien dans l'eau pensée ou c'est un
chèque a peur de l'eau sacha il s'en bat
les couilles il s'en bat les couilles on
va aller profond profond il vient pas le
chien
ok j'ai compris fall a tiré à gauche et
ensuite on passe en dessous de lui en
fait au hall planches non le plan a
échoué à être lancés au cerveau à mars
au plus tard il m'a fait peur ce qu'on
dégage dégage des comme ça je pense ça
nous laisse un peu plus de temps à lons
casse
c'est chaud et ça va encore passer mais
à un poil de cul voilà j'avais raison
alors qu'à ce [ __ ] voilà j'en ai marre
de l'inflation gratuite au nom il faut
pas été la grille c'est sûr c'est sûr
j'ai très peu tôt pour acheter ses
planches de bois soient les tensions
jetant du toit voici notre côté pour
venir [ __ ] hop on a eu celle là on
repart et qui partent on y retournera à
nice au combat et ils sont très contents
alors pour les gages voilà ça les gars
jean-marie cannes on est bien [ __ ] ces
satanés chien mais qu'il est encore des
bâtiments les égouts mais c'est une
forteresse mec c'est incroyable ok bah
voilà bah écoutez c'est une très bonne
manière de terminer ce deuxième épisode
n'hésitez pas à aller mais ça vous a plu
écoutez j'ai envie d'en savoir plus on
veut savoir qui sont ces gens pourquoi
ils ont biffé d'autres gens et qu'est ce
qu'ils font avec la tant de questions
qui restent sans réponse et on aurait
besoin d'un smicard squeeze là il est en
vacances monde aurait besoin de lui à
l'instant filtré dans le prochain
épisode merci d'avoir gardé portez vous
bien à tout le monde puisse